Mass Effect Andromeda we got a dev diary
well yeah I think they're just gonna
hold off for games coming out next year
so they'll wonder focus on battlefield
they want to focus on titanfall but I
was really to be honest I was expecting
less footage I was expecting I'm just
like again the concept art stuff but
what was interesting is that the concept
are that they were showing is the
concept that we saw it like two years
ago but this time fleshed out characters
in it better lighting effects more
movement and also first like a
protagonist who everyone was crying out
for fem shep in the original trilogy to
be the face of the trilogy and it looks
like they're leading with that that's
about all yeah like that one should hear
the tempest looks an awful lot like
Normandy yeah but what I can like this
cuz you also got to see a relay is that
they're kind of holding on to the old
mass effect in specially in terms of hmm
like just the look of it and some of the
Keystone's like like the like the
Citadel those kind of things and some of
the creatures and races but they aren't
afraid to be injecting new things like
this yeah feature here these new
environments so we get Cena sorry she's
definitely in there and I think what
looks like a yog which with the shadow
broker was so it's this real mashup of
old and new and I am super excited I'm
getting the impression like I think
planet explorations gonna be great I
mean cuz we know we know the Makos on
board we've known that for a while which
means I'm sure we're gonna be back on
the ground again and that's been less of
a focus more on the cities and things
like that presidium and all that so I
think that's gonna be awesome and just
like how dedicated they seem to be too
how alien everything is gonna be
ironically where the alien but I think
that's gonna be great we're gonna see
less humans we're gonna see them
branching out more I think like trying
out you know different themes of planets
different races and just you know they
know they can deep dive into law and
into like just completely invented
spaces and that we're going to lap it up
yeah so I think like because I've got
all that backing we should see some
super good [ __ ] exciting stuff
you